Speaker 1: We are going to hear from some
of you today.
We are going to speak to people via The David
Pakman Show discord, which is it's the hot
new thing.
To quote the former guy.
You can find it at David Pakman dotcom slash
discord.
Let's go to Billy from California, Billy from
California.
You're on the air.
Speaker 2: Yes.
Listen, the New York state attorney general
has announced that they're going to start
investigating the Trump organization, not
just to civil capacity, but, yes, criminal
capacity.
Speaker 1: That's right.
We covered it.
So there's basically two things going on.
The Cy Vance investigation was criminal all
along.
The Letitia James investigation was civil.
It is now criminal.
You are one hundred percent correct, my friend.
Speaker 2: Sure.
And my question is, when are you going to
start pandering to your audience a little
bit and dispel with this fiction that Donald
Trump is never going to get arrested in the
United States, doesn't arrest presidents?
Speaker 1: I still believe that.
I mean, listen, I don't pander one way or
the other.
What I say on this program is what I believe.
I you know, they're investigating the Trump
organization criminally.
I think that if it reaches Trump, it will
be civil.
And I think if it if criminal charges would
be against people other than Trump and even
if Trump is charged, I think there's no perp
walk.
I think there's no jail time.
Speaker 2: If you think people listen to Ben
Shapiro because they think his tics are interesting,
don't listen to him because he tells them
what they want to hear.
You got to be a little bit tell us exactly
how the perp walk is going to go down.
Right, exactly.
The jumpsuit cell, if you want to hear it
all.
But then what
Speaker 1: happens is when it never happens,
coming, when it never happens, then people
call in and say, David, why were you saying
Trump was going to get arrested?
And I'd have to be like, you know, I never
really believe that I did it for Billy in
California.
Speaker 2: That's fine.
That's fine.
Speaker 1: Then I look stupid.
Then I look even stupider than I normally
look.
Speaker 2: Well, it's a hard bar to bear,
but we'll leave it at that.
Anyways, thanks, David, I appreciate your
honesty, actually, and for not giving us any
sense of false hope, but I am still hopeful
that at some point justice is going to be
served.
Yes.
I mean, we all want to see him in a prison
cell, but I would
Speaker 1: love to see Trump perp walked in
handcuffs.
Believe me, I would love it.
I just would be lying if I told you I think
it's going to happen.
Speaker 5: I hear you.
Speaker 1: Yeah, all right, my friend Billy
from California, very important topic.
I appreciate it.